Замість одного газопостачальника - місцевого облгазу - майже 50-т різних компаній.
З відкриттям незалежного газового ринку в Україні споживачі вперше отримали можливість
обирати собі газопостачальника і кращу ціну.
Усю процедуру можна зробити швидко і безболісно онлайн.
Мешканець селища Іванковичі під Києвом Андрій Василишин зробив це ще восени.
Паперова робота переходу від "Київоблгазу" до "Нафтогазу"  зайняла 10 хвилин.
Відсканував посвідчення особи, документи на будинок, надав свій газовий АЙ-СІ ІС-код,
оформив заяву про зміну постачальника, підписав цифровим підписом, відправив, отримав підтвердження.
Андрій системний адміністратор, тому з електронним сервісом розібрався дуже швидко.
Нескладно для нього було й визначитися з новим газопостачальником.
Його родині на рік треба приблизно 4000 кубів газу і бажано за річним пакетом,
аби виплачувати вартість спожитого взимку газу впродовж цілого року.
Я обрав річний тариф по 5,24 за куб.
Наприклад, у "Київгаззбуті" я взагалі  не пам’ятаю, що в них можна було обрати річний тариф,
тому що кожен місяць змінюється ціна.
Наприклад, в грудні-листопаді було 8,82. Це різниця в 3,60 на кубі.
А в січні взагалі 9,87 за куб. Якщо так порахувати, це виходить 14 000 гривень економії за один рік.
Щоправда, не обійшлося без казусів. Через місяць після переходу до "Нафтогазу"
Андрій неочікувано отримав платіжку від старого газопостачальника.
Моя заявка трохи загубилася у менеджерів. Аж через два місяці,
коли я отримав вже другу платіжку від "Київобгаззбуту", почав з’ясовувати,
чому досі приходять рахунки. І виявилося, що мене просто ще не зареєстрували.
Подібні випадки, як пояснили DW в "Нафтогазі", далеко не поодинокі.
Оператори просто не встигали обробляти заявки.
За даними компанії, щодня надходило до 20 000 нових заявок від споживачів про намір перейти до "Нафтогазу"
і з осені реєстр їхніх побутових споживачів збільшився з 250 двохсот п'ятдесяти тисяч до мільйона.
Часто працівникам "Нафтогазу" доводилося ще додатково розбиратися з історіями,
коли перехід споживачів буквально блокували місцеві облгази.
Людей без їхнього відома, як тільки вони перейшли до "Нафтогазу",
перевели назад до старого постачальника. Споживачі були шоковані.
Переводили туди-сюди, якщо не помиляюся, по 5 разів без їхнього відома.
Також є порушення, що людей, які перейшли до "Нафтогазу", просто тероризують:
психологічно, фізично відключають, починаються якісь перевірки можливих порушень,
яких не помічали раніше в проекті, який той же облгаз погоджував і реалізовував.
Саме так відбулося у випадку Юлії Назаренко з Лубен.
Жінка хотіла відмовитися від послуг місцевого газопостачальника "Лубнигазу",
подала заяву на річний пакет від "Нафтогазу", але зрештою замість газу від нового постачальника
вона взагалі залишилася без блакитного палива. Її будинок у листопаді без попередження
відімкнули від газопостачання співробітники місцевого облгазу.
Нам сказали, що в нас безліч недоліків: не пройдений техогляд, замуровані труби
і в нас котел не відповідає документації. Чому нам 11 років не було взагалі ніяких зауважень?
Чому це сталося в той момент, коли ми вирішили змінити постачальника?
На вимогу газовиків, Юлія за власні кошти усунула всі недоліки.
Проте і після цього не вдалося перейти до "Нафтогазу", якому вона вже почала оплачувати спожиті куби.
Я вже три рази пройшла оформлення процедури. Я думала, що ми в "Нафтогазі" з 5 листопада.
Яке моє було здивування, коли ми отримали рахунок за листопад від "Лубнигазу"!
Я до них: як таке може бути, якщо ми перейшли до "Нафтогазу"? Я ж упевнена!
Ми ж не подавали заяви про приєднання назад до "Лубнигазу". Мені кажуть: ні, мовляв, ви не перейшли.
"Нафтогаз" з’ясував,  що нас назад забрав "Лубнигаз".
Після того я подала заявку 8  грудня до "Нафтогазу" і якимось дивом після 20 грудня ми знову в "Лубнигазі".
Це як? Вони знову нас виставляють на платформу і знову без нашої згоди забирають!
Як це можна назвати? Це неправомірні дії!
Коордоинаторка з житлово-комунальних та енергетичних програм
громадської мережі "Опора" Тетяну Бойко такі випадки обурюють.
Якщо відбулася автоматична зміна постачальника, то це означає,
що старий постачальник фактично підробив заявку споживача,
тому що без заявки споживача він не може вчинити такі дії. Це шантаж, це залякування споживачів.
Задля підтримки споживачів у подібних випадках громадянська мережа "Опора"
розробила спеціальний інформаційний портал, де прописані і правила функціонування незалежного газового ринку,
є покрокові інструкції, як діяти в різних проблемних ситуаціях та куди звертатися.
Згідно із законом, головною інстанцією, яка має оперативно допомагати споживачам
вирішувати конфлікти з газопостачальниками, є Національна комісія,
що здійснює державне регулювання у сферах енергетики та комунальних послуг.
Проте, за спостереженнями мережі "Опора", до роботи комісії є чимало питань.
Я утримаюся від коментарів про їхню незалежність і незаангажованість.
Але однозначно, що туди треба звертитися. По-перше, це не боятися і написати претензії
до свого постачальника, до свого облгазу. І відразу пишіть скаргу до НКРЕКП,
до територіального відділення і краще дублювати в центральне відділення.
Очевидно, якщо ви не отримали відповіді і нічого не змінилося,
то варто звертатися до місцевих активістів і журналістів, щоб ця проблема стала публічною.
Тому що дуже складно залишатися один на один з цією проблемою.
Саме так і зробила Юлія Назаренко. Вона повідомила про свою проблему місцевим активістам,
які мають намір подати колективний позов від мешканців району на місцевий "Лубнигаз".
Юлія подала скаргу і до НКРЕКП, аби та перевірила дії газовиків.
Також до комісії зі скаргами про блокування переходу споживачів часто звертається й "Нафтогаз".
Наші інтереси також зачіпаються, тому що ми втрачаємо споживача.
Ми скаржимося теж до регулятора. Ми подавали досить багато скарг
на дії інших учасників. Вони розглядаються, призначені перевірки.
Після тарифних протестів уряд поки тимчасово обмежив ціну на газ для населення.
Громадські захисники прав споживачів радять українцям використати цей час,
аби зорієнтуватися на новому для них ринку блакитного палива і заздалегідь дізнатися
про механізм зміни газопостачальника, про ціни й умови газових договорів від різних операторів.
На думку громадських активістів, це свідчить про те, що незалежний ринок газу в Україні
попри все розвивається і має шанс стати привабливим і для іноземних інвестицій,
і для незалежних вітчизняних компаній.
Поки за тими тенденціями, які ми бачимо на ринку, то маленькі, незалежні компанії тримаються.
Станом на нині є 8 компаній, які оприлюднили ціну навіть менше, ніж 6,99.
Держава має захищати маленькі компанії, щоб всі були в рівних умовах.
Громадські активісти та місцеві громади ініціюють розробку нового газового кодексу,
який захищав би не лише постачальників, а й споживачів.